[Musik]
so klingt Gangster Rap in ecador ein
Loblied auf Banden Boss fito der im
Gefängnis Kontakte pflegt und liebevoll
Geflügel
züchtet überhaupt sei er voller Liebe
trellert seine Tochter in seinen Adern
fließe gutes
Blut von dem Blut das auf euadors
Straßen in Strömen fließt hört man
nichts bekümmert im Knast Musikvideos
drehte sollte eigentlich noch 21 Jahre
wegen Raub Mord und Drogenhandel
absitzen aber am 7 Januar ist er
ausgebrochen und seitdem herrscht Angst
in
[Musik]
Ecuador Armee an den Grenzen Armee in
der
Stadt und beinahe täglich Armee in den
Gefängnissen wo die Drogenbanden
und sonst nur Korruption Gewalt und
Rechtlosigkeit wo Mord und Meuterei
genauso alltäglich sind wie
Waffenverstecke und eine gut bestückte
Minibar früher waren Gefängnisse Schulen
des Verbrechens heute sind sie Fabriken
und Büros des Verbrechens ihre
Gewalttaten steuern die Gangs auch aus
den Gefängnissen heraus
damit soll jetzt Schluss sein verkündete
der Präsident nachdem er die narkogangs
zu Terroristen erklärt hatte und den
Krieg gegen sie zur nationalen
Überlebensfrage Armee und Polizei haben
order erhalten die Kontrolle in den
Gefängnissen zu übernehmen dazu habe ich
ein notstandsdekret unterzeichnet ich
rufe alle Bürger auf diese Maßnahme zu
unterstützen stellt die Truppe Slams und
drogenhotspots auf den Kopf die üblichen
Verdächtigen arbeitslose junge Männer
Nachwuchs für die Banden 2 Millionen
sollen ohne Job
sein ich habe doch gar nichts gemacht
nicht geraucht und keine Drogen ich
arbeite da
drüben und da wird schon die nächste
Busladung von mutmaßlichen gangngstern
auf den Weg ins ohnehin überfüllte
Gefängnis gebracht sie sollen versucht
haben ein Krankenhaus zu stürmen zwei
Banden sind es vor allem die das Land
terrorisieren beide mit tausenden
Mitgliedern die kroneros mit dem
entsprungenen fito aus dem Musikvideo
und Los Lobos die sind hier zu sehen wie
sie die Ermordung eines Politikers
feiern eines von 8000 Opfern im
vergangenen
Jahr und jetzt tobt eine neue gewaltie
in den Gefängnissen wo die Häftlinge
ihre Bewacher als Geiseln nahmen oder im
Fernsehstudio aus dem 20 Minuten lang
diese Bilder gesendet wurden bevor die
Polizei die Angreifer
überwältigte dann wurde ein Staatsanwalt
ermordet und spätestens damit war für
Joffre etcheveria der Ofen aus sein
Restaurant in der Altstadt von Kito
bleibt meist geschlossen es herrschen
Ausgangssperre und Todesangst und da
denkt keiner an espresso und
Kartoffeleintopf
es hagelt überall nur noch absagen
manche Hotels haben 80 oder 90% ihrer
Buchungen verloren überall sind die
Umsätze dramatisch
eingebrochen mit knapp 3000 Höhenmetern
ist Kito eine der höchstgelegenen
Metropolen der Welt und die Luft wird
immer dünner die coronapandemie hat
Equador schwer zugesetzt viele
Todesopfer gefordert und die Wirtschaft
abgewirkt und gerade als ich die
Gastronomie erholte sind die Straßen nun
abermals touristenfrei und die örtliche
Kundschaft speist vorsichtshalber
daheim wenn die Mieten weiterbezahlt
werden müssen auch wenn die nachfageage
sinkt dann müssen die Restaurants die
Hotels und die Bars dicht
machen und dann leidet die ganze Branche
mit samt ihrer
Zulieferer das einzige Geschäft das in
diesem Land boomt wie nie sind Drogen
täglich melden die Behörden neue Funde
und der Einfallsreichtum der Schmuggler
ist unerschöpflich dieses Tauchboot hat
die Marine auf hoher See aufgebracht mit
3 Tonnen Kokain im Laderaum der Stoff
kommt aus Kolumbien Bolivien und Peru
wird über Ecuadors Häfen verschifft
nicht selten versteckt zwischen Bananen
gelangt es auch nach
Europa berüchtigten mexikanischen
killerkartelle und die Albanische Mafia
kontrollieren den Handel mit
ecadorianern als
Handlanger die müssen nicht mal
umrechnen können der US-Dollar ist hier
Landeswährung das erleichtert die
Abwicklung Ecuadors Traum sich als
Traumziel für Taucher Wanderer und
Naturfreunde zu empfehlen scheint
jedenfalls vorerst
ausgeträumt denn nicht einmal die
Schildkröten und leguana auf Ecuadors
Galapagosinseln bleiben vom
Kokainschmuggel verschont die einsamen
Buchten des Weltnaturerbes sind gute
Waffenverstecke und die Fischer
verkaufen den Schmugglern gern ihren
Treibstoff zu
Mondpreisen und auch wenn immer mal
wieder eines ihrer Tauchboote erwischt
wird viele andere kommen durch und so
geht ein weiter kleines Paradies V die
Hunde